good morning Hank it's Wednesday that's
not a green-screen I'm really in
Amsterdam so Hank I'm here in Amsterdam
for two months finishing my new book the
reason I'm in Amsterdam will become
obvious when you read the book also the
Yeti needs to be in Europe because she's
working on the u.s. Pavilion for the
Venice Biennale very fancy and so
everybody has a reason to be here say
hello to the tram except for Henry but
you know he's portable by the way just
to orient you we're going to the flower
market right Hank so back in the early
1600s when tubes first came to Holland
they were prized for the richness of
their color but there were these
multicolored ones that were particularly
beloved so most to look like the tulips
you're used to seeing like these but
there were these rare and fragile and
sickly looking bulbs that made beautiful
tulips like the Viceroy more on him in a
second right so throughout the first
half of the 1630s don't worry this is
not going to hit me
the price of tulips rose pretty steadily
and by the winner of 1636 Hank the Dutch
had become total tulip maniacs
particularly for those sickly looking
bulbs that made brilliant flowers like
the a fir mentioned Viceroy for the
amount of money a single Viceroy bulb
cost in 1637 you could have bought all
of this I mean Hank forget the Rye in
the fat ox and I think I could live
happily ever after with just a suit of
clothes a complete bed in 4,000 pounds
of butter that common probably didn't
make sense to the people standing behind
me and then in 1637 pretty much all at
once the market for tulip bulbs
completely collapsed falling like 99% in
two months it was one of the first great
bubbles of capitalism Hank but that's
not what fascinates me here's what
fascinates me those fragile looking
bulbs that made brilliant flowers like
the Viceroy it turns out they were sick
with a virus called the tulip mosaic
virus they've all long since died out
and while we can look at paintings we
will never know quite what it felt like
to see the Viceroy I first heard of
tulip mania in Atlas by Katrina
Vandenberg this brilliant book of poems
that has shaped my thinking a lot while
writing this new book here's how she put
it
aren't you sorry you will never see a
tulip that would make you offer all you
own for the layered translucent promise
in its brown paper wrapper Hank I'll see
you on Friday